- The internet is full of
fun and inspiring stories.
Once you, you know, delete all the trolls.
I find the best of the
best and present them here.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
So check out these photos, y'all.
It looks like delicious
breakfast cereal, right?
I know, like childhood, right?
Maybe some Fruit Loops, some Trix.
I don't know.
It's your dealer's choice.
Well, it's the internet people.
So of course, that's wrong.
They're candles.
They're actual frickin' candles.
And the best part is they actually smell
(Kelly inhales)
like the real thing.
And I would know.
(Kelly laughs)
These are the creation of
a 23 year old entrepreneur
who's documenting his entire
business journey on TikTok.
Say hi to Kobe, y'all.
(audience claps)
Hi, Kobe!
- Hey!
Hello.
- I mean, well done with the smell.
It smells just like it.
It's crazy.
So, you're very young to
like, start a business.
So, how long have you been making candles?
- I have been making
candles for eight years now.
I started back when I was 15 years old.
I always knew I wanted
to start my own business.
And so, I took entrepreneurship
class in high school.
And after that, I thought, why wait?
And so, my freshman year of high school
I started Ardent Candle.
And now, eight years later,
it's grown into a million dollar business,
hires 10 full-time employees.
- [Kelly] What?
And we have a 5,000 square foot warehouse.
It's just been insane.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
Way to take a class
seriously is all I'm saying.
So wait, you say that
your parents are probably
your biggest supporters, right?
- Yeah.
My parents had a huge impact
on this whole journey.
Growing up, my parents were entrepreneurs.
So, I looked up to that.
Like, when I was in school
and people would say,
what do you wanna be when you grow up?
I was always saying, I wanna be the boss
'cause that's my parents did.
And when I was starting my business,
my dad actually told me if
I wrote a business plan,
he would gimme the
money I needed to start.
So I did that.
My dad gave me 200 bucks and
that's how the company started.
And my mom played a
huge part in my business
growing to where it is today
because once I started going
super viral on TikTok,
I was also a full time college student
and I wasn't gonna be able
to manage all of that.
But my mom came to me
and said, look, Kobe,
I know this is what you wanna do
and it might make sense for
you to take a break from school
to focus on your business.
And that's not a typical parent's response
but I'm like, so grateful
that my mom, you know,
said that to me 'cause it
- Yeah!
- really helped me take the leap and go
and now it's grown to something so big,
bigger than we all ever thought.
- Absolutely.
And sometimes college is all about
you don't know what
you wanna do, you know?
So it helps you figure that out.
And if you do know what
you wanna do, it's kind of,
it's important to focus on that dream.
So thank you so much, Kobe.
You've got great parents as well.
Way to go.
(audience claps)
I'm liking your post right
now, along with your candle.
(heart dings)
And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly
Clarkson Show, wants to
honor ultimate overachievers
just like you, sir.
So they're gonna be writin'
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Oh, wow!
Thank you!
(Kelly laughs)
- You are killin' it, Kobe.
- That's insane.
Thank you so much.
- Absolutely.
Keep making these candles.
They smell delicious.